[Aplausos]
ahorita les vamos a enseñar un pequeño
vídeo
y a
a
[Aplausos]
si el joven no te limita a hacer grandes
cosas la primera vez que fue a la selva
tenía sólo un año mi papá siempre me
llevaban a la selva porque yo trabajaban
con los indígenas secoyas los secoyas
son una minoría étnica de apenas 500
personas del ecuador y mil personas en
perú
el pueblo que yo siempre visitaba se
llama mañoco siempre que iba acá me
gustaba pasar con mis amigos de cosas
con ellos nadaba jugaba pasado pasé casi
todo el tiempo con ellos
por razones de la vida deje de ir a la
selva por un tiempo me acuerdo que soy
me dolió mucho porque siempre que iba a
la selva la pasaba muy bien y siempre me
conectaba con la naturaleza después de
nueve años tuve la oportunidad de volver
a ir
entonces después de 13 horas de canoa me
bajé y busca en mis amigos y cosas
pero no estaban ahí
me contaron que todos ellos se habían
ido a la ciudad algunos a buscar trabajo
otro día estaban casados y algunos ya
tenían hijos los 15 años y no podía
entender como niños de 15 años he venido
solo de la ciudad sin sus papás no
entendía por qué no estaban estudiando
al beber quito no me puede quitar esto
de la cabeza no podía entender cómo
niños de mi edad no estaban estudiando
con estos nueve años yo estuve yendo a
la escuela aprendiendo cosas nuevas
mientras ellos estaban migrando a la
ciudad buscando oportunidades
entonces hablé con una amiga
con ella decidimos hacer algo sabemos
que no estaba bien que niños se queden
sin una educación
sabíamos que ya los niños de mi edad lo
habían perdido todo y estaban con
familia
pero los de otras generaciones no
entonces decidimos hacer algo para
cambiar el futuro de estos niños pero
como no teníamos dinero no sabíamos ni
por dónde empezar
entonces buscamos ayuda sabíamos que
queríamos hacer una escuela
lo primero que hice fue hablar con mis
profesores les cuento un poco de mi
proyecto les dije que quería hacer una
escuela en la amazonía pero no me
tomaron en serio se rieron de mí y me
dijeron que no era posible que una niña
de 15 años construye una escuela en la
mitad de la nada
entonces estoy donde mis papás les conté
de mi proyecto les dije que quería hacer
algo para que los niños de otras
generaciones no se quedaran sin una
educación y se quedaran en el pueblo de
sus ancestros
tampoco me creyeron
nadie me creía capaz de hacer esto
entonces sabía que tenía que hacer algo
para que me crean sabía que tenía que
demostrar lo que era capaz de hacer
como me hizo una fiesta
en esta fiesta rica de 1200 dólares no
era tanto para hacer una escuela al
menos pero era lo suficiente para
demostrarles a mis papás de lo que yo
era capaz de hacer
así que esa misma noche fui donde mis
papás con el dinero en las manos y les
dije aquí está
es la prueba de que yo puedo ser capaz
de hacer algo por esta comunidad
mis papás obviamente no podían escribir
toda la plata que les estaba entregando
en las manos me preguntaron de dónde
saqué y todo y les conté que es una
fiesta entonces les pedí que me compren
un ticket para irme a lima quería ir a
hablar con el ministerio de educación
del perú porque quería pedirles ayuda y
apoyo con esta escuela
quizá para sorprendidos por todo lo que
les estaba diciendo en ese momento
decidieron apoyarme
dijeron que me iban a acompañar al imán
pero que guarde ese dinero porque ellos
sabían que iba a fundar una escuela con
lo que me quedaba
entonces fuimos a lima fui a el
ministerio de educación del perú con una
cita que había pedido y me escucharon
les conté más o menos la idea del
proyecto les conté que eran 10 niños que
vivían en esa comunidad aislada y que no
tienen una educación
entonces ellos localizaron en el mapa la
escuela y me dijeron que no me podían
ayudar manteniendo una escuela en un
lugar tan aislado
pero me dijeron que podían ayudarme
construyendo un aula de clases y un aula
de clases era lo único que yo necesitaba
yo podía contratar un profesor no sé de
dónde pero podía
entonces volvía quieto feliz de que me
podían ayudar con un aula de clases
en ese momento con mi amiga empezamos a
buscar gente que nos podía ayudar con el
proyecto y sí pues un grupo de seis
personas y con ellos empezamos a hacer
la escuela hemos hecho eventos hacemos
como uno a uno cada mes
y con esa plata financiamos la escuela
compramos materiales le pagamos al
profesor mensualmente y tenemos esta
plata para cualquier cosa que necesite
bueno y así es como nace mi proyecto
vieron del arto coche el principal
objetivo de mi proyecto es ayudar y
mejorar la educación de los niños y
collas
nuestro primer viaje fue en febrero del
aquí les traje a mis otros compañeros
que no conocían la amazonía y se
enamoraron de la belleza que es y
también de los niños obviamente en este
viaje hicimos un test para saber cuándo
sabían los niños les preguntamos cosas
de libros enseñamos números y ellos no
sabían leer ni escribir ni nada
contratamos al profesor y después de un
año volvimos y ya sabían leer escribir
les encantaba la poesía
muchos dirán genios en matemáticas en
arte
entonces fue increíble ir y ver como
pudimos cambiar la vida de 10 niños 10
niños no es mucho pero es algo y tenemos
que empezar por ahí
también el 15 de mayo de este año
fundamos nuestra segunda escuela que es
en banquina peque de este pueblo que
queda a ocho horas en canoa de coca
entonces gracias a nosotros gracias
había una carta cacha 30 indígenas se
que ellas tienen acceso a una educación
y en esta educación que nosotros les
damos no nos restringimos a vestirse
como quieran a peinarse como quieran oa
pensar como quieran sino que les
motivamos a alimentar su cultura en esta
escuela ellos aprenden literatura
historia música ciencias pero también
aprenden de su cultura porque nosotros
no queremos que se pierda su cultura y
es por eso que no queríamos que estos
niños se vayan de este pueblo porque
este pueblo es estratégico para los
secoyas porque queda justo en la
frontera con el perú y el ecuador
entonces desde el punto de encuentro de
los secoyas peruanos y ecuatorianos
entonces quiero que me ayuden
compartiendo esta historia
quiero que entiendan que la edad no
importa
lo que importa es con cuánta pasión
hacen las cosas y qué tan dispuestos
están por cumplir sus sueños
así que piensen en lo que realmente
quieran y sigan adelante y pongan su
tiempo y energía en las cosas que de
verdad no importan crean nuevas ideas
quieren vínculos con las personas que
les van a tomar en serio
hagan las propuestas
y cuando sientan que el momento es el
correcto asegúrense de hacer lo único
que les ayudará a conseguir lo que de
verdad quieren
preguntar
[Aplausos]